tv music awards conor mcgregor
reportedly tried to fight machine gun
kelly because mgk didn't want to take a
picture with them we know why conor is
angry at machine gun kelly on sunday
videos of conor mcgregor trying to
attack the rapper mg at the vma surface
on the internet uh sources connected to
the situation paid that connor asked mgk
for photo which kelly denied and that
apparently escalated into him push and
counter who stumbled back and spilled
his drink when he collected himself and
whatever was left of his drink connor
allegedly chucked the drink at kelly as
well as megan who was nearby their
prospective teams broke up broke it up
before things got ugly and conor was
given his walk and came back something
that had fallen to the ground during the
scuffle thank god he got his came back
but thank goodness tell me what do you
think about what happened i think uh
just real quick uh this guy
machine gun kelly is dating
megan fox he is better than by the way
what country is she from america america
damn america
dick your russian known megan
fox is known for phenomenal banter just
so you know from the moment
i'm telling you again from the moment
her and shia labeouf were not in
transformers i was done yeah i went on
strike i said i'm done people don't know
this but in your top five actors of all
time shia labeouf is in it not top five
but i'm a die hard child like listen i'm
also a die hard edward norton fan i
think these two guys are legit but i'm
also i like a andy garcia i like some
strange actors i like john bernthal i
think john is a beast of an actor but
yeah i would say shy is up there for me
but go ahead so yeah
all right so i it was the mtv music
awards by the way do you even watch that
anymore no i don't watch the empty music
any awards anymore stop it you were
taking notes on your i do watch the
clips of it afterwards to see what's
going on i think bieber one artist of
the year yeah i don't watch it but i
know bieber one here we go i'm a bieber
fan all right i'm gonna be your fan like
you're a child of buffet but i also like
bieber i think bieber's a stud well
let's name three songs of bieber yeah i
would have to if you
i don't know the name of the songs okay
but i like the one song he did lately
about a year ago when he's sitting there
by himself singing about being lonely as
a kid performing nobody was going back
with him that messaging i think it was
called lonely lonely it could have been
great there's two two versions of the
video is it too late to say i'm sorry
no i don't think it is okay i don't
think it is all right what do you mean
these are bieber songs anyway
but
was there to i think introduce the wind
of the song of the year anyway he was
there
um
to introduce uh one of the categories
but he showed up
and i think
the story here isn't machine gun kelly
the only reason the machine gun kelly is
relevant in my opinion is because he's
dating megan fox if he was just some
dude that was just this rapper i think
he'd be irrelevant that's not true
though
the dude took uh he went from being a
rapper with beef with eminem to turning
into the lead singer of some 41 and
nobody even blinked an eye like he's
he's actually pretty the fact that he
has beef with eminem
it is laughable to me he's nowhere close
to being where the rap god loves
but that one song he put was pretty
legit the lyrics you put out that was
actually not bad machine gun kelly yes
never heard it i'm not a fan i don't
know it
anyway i thought it was pretty decent
i think the story here is from croatia
just saying no no okay it makes sense go
ahead i have no clue if it's croatia
cleveland no yeah he's from definitely
america
leaflet but it is impressive how megyn
kelly hypes him up she calls him the
most beautiful boy
the most talented that i say megan kelly
i do love megan kelly megan fox by the
way machine gun kelly megan fox just
come on but here's the story guys
what's your point
i think connor is having a meltdown
i think connor he just needed to win he
needed a win
he could beat this skinny beanpole
rapper i think connor
is his best days are behind him he's
made his money you interviewed dustin
poirier and he said quote unquote it's
kind of hard to get up and put in the
work and run your miles when you're
sleeping in satin sheets something like
that yeah so i think conor's made his
money he's made his name he's turning
into more of a celebrity influencer
he's walking around with a cane well his
foot has fallen off i don't know if he's
ever gonna fight at the level that he
was and this is sort of like a pr stunt
to keep his name in the news that's my
two cents yeah i haven't fought in five
years but even five years ago uh guys i
was fighting with that are really really
big names in the ufc guys i was in like
fight camps for and stuff like that they
would tell me
like dude never bet on mcgregor ever
again like he he parties too hard he
goes way way too far
irish whiskey bro you know
yeah basically blanton's at proper 12.
uh the uh
but as as a guy who who drank way too
much whiskey and did too many dumb
things himself
until
you get to a certain age where you know
look the problem when you're a good
fighter and the problem when you're a
bigger dude even though conor's not but
he's very good fighter he's very tough
and you're a boozer and you're doing
whatever comes with the booze you're a
tornado of destruction nobody can stop
you see one of the big problems one of
the reasons i don't drink hard alcohol
anymore is because nobody could stop me
and i i was good at drinking so i
wouldn't black
i wouldn't black out so where most other
people would pass out or you know
somebody else would be able to grab them
and throw them in a car they couldn't do
that with me i was too big and i was too
violent and like i would just turn into
a non-stop life-destroying menace until
finally like it it slows down do you not
get the irony here you're wearing an
ireland green iron shirt
it would be like me saying a jewish guy
goes on on radio every day saying save
that money
pat you've interviewed dustin poirier i
know you're a fan of cog connor what's
your take on all this i don't know i
think uh i think uh you know if you if
you look at it from there's a few
different ways to look at it number one
it's very hard one of the hardest things
to do
is
when you're when you're uh this happens
to a lot of different people but when
you are extremely attractive and all of
a sudden you get to an age and you're
not getting the attention you got
psychologically that messes with you
women oh my gosh that by the way it's
torture
it's torture
and that's why sometimes a young boy can
always you know sometimes get together
with a
older woman 45 50 because it's a
confirmation from the older woman to say
a 22 year old is still attracted to me
it's nothing coach and demi moore it's a
form of confirmation right by the way it
happens to everybody so that's one
example great angle this is paralleling
tyson pretty tightly though yeah yeah so
so then by the way even tyson talked
about mcgregor tyson talked about
mcgregor in the interview tyson's
interview has got to be one of my top
five interviews of all time the guy was
hilarious by the way that the plane
reference was the funniest thing he was
just hilarious period yeah can't cancel
me i got my own
so and then so so that's that's the
woman side right and then
for athletes
you go from a lamar odom do you kidding
me you're a champion you're a laker
everybody's following you all of a
sudden
nobody like do you when's the last time
you googled lamar odom yeah he fought uh
aaron carter actually answered that
question when's the last time you
googled lamar odom he he got kardashian
and he got done right
so he stood up and chewed up and yeah on
the other side so but think about how
many times that happens to athletes it's
tough psychologically it's tough right
it happens to boxers it happens to
athletes and there's a part of it that i
think it's the fault of
the game is the fault of the sport it's
the fault of somebody not shaping the
character of that becoming a reality at
dinner with a couple this week and the
incredible dinner we were at eddie v's
and uh uh
their uh three-year-old daughter died
they're on vacation they come back they
have no idea what's going on all of a
sudden their three-year-old
dies
by the way i mean you know we're talking
about nature went to a completely
different angle story-wise and he sits
there and i'm like
i couldn't even talk to an entire night
like to me my stomach hurt i was just
feeling like i'm hearing this now i
don't even want to hear about it right
but my stomach hurts i'm like you know i
can't even eat the food we're ordering
nice food and it's like they're just
sitting there being very you know
christian family they're being strong
about it and they're like listen it was
very tough but we had to overcome this
and all this stuff
and and uh they said the one thing that
kids that parents don't do enough
talking to their kids about is the idea
of death this is because you don't even
think about it now that took me
immediately back when i was six years
old and we're getting bombed on and my
dad sat down and talked to me about
dying like what is the matter with this
guy he's saying one day i'm gonna die i
said you know no you're not gonna die
says one day i'm gonna die says you have
to understand that
if i die you have to be happy i said why
do i have to be happy he said because
you had six years with your dad many
people don't even have a dad in their
lives i said you mean to tell me when
your mom dies you're not gonna cry he
says no i'm thankful i've had my mom for
so many years i'm going to be happy with
the smile i said no you're not he says
watch me
so his mom dies at 72 from cancer
and i go and i see him because you know
as a kid as a boy i've been watching
this man for my entire life i'm like let
me see let me see how much this guy's
gonna be real with me or not and i watch
him he had a smile on his face
your dad and he had a smile on his face
he's nice guys freaking my dad he had a
smile on his face his eyes are filled up
and i'm looking at this guy i'm like
what a freaking man you are right and
he's telling stories and he's saying all
these great things about you know my mom
this my mom then my mom this like you
got to freaking appreciate this guy so
there is lessons in
somebody like a dana sitting there
having the serious convert i think the
sports game got to do that i think
somebody's got to do that with women
with celebrities to say connor
here's where you are
let me just kind of paint this picture
for you and you tell me what you want to
do you've lost three matches alone in a
row okay
you're now
getting unnecessary attention you don't
need the last time you got unnecessary
attention like this is when you threw
that uh what do you call it in the box
right it wasn't a chair it was a what
was it it was a the bench and he ended
up that poor guy's career with yeah yeah
i mean it was like what are you doing it
for is it attention what do you do and
then you go and you come out with your
drink and you punch the guy in the face
at a bar oh dude and then later on you
buy that bar and oh dude didn't even
flinch by the way yeah he just continued
right
so some of these meltdowns someone has
to have a serious conversation now
here's the other part if he doesn't have
if he doesn't receive it the onus is all
on who
on the individual yeah and then you got
to say look we have the conversation he
still chooses to live this life but i
think conor has an opportunity right now
because he's so
big right now with his name
if he figured out a way to transition
into another field if he if he was able
to do look at daniel cormier if he was
able to do it the world forgets about
all the look at how many times cormier
lost that yeah cormier is done he's he's
a guy that's going to get that respect
he's just got to figure right away to go
there but i don't think the kind of
attention that he was getting for that
five-year period seven year period i
don't think that's coming you brought up
a lot of amazing points pat
you know everything with your dad is
incredible um it's emotional as well
something to be said about conor's when
you're winning
you can kind of get away with some of
the antics right some of it is
justifiable it's almost marketing pr but
when you're losing
it just seems sad desperate yeah and
desperate well there's two two parts of
that man well the first part is i've
talked to you about this i have a theory
and it's i think guys
do self-destructive things in these
positions because it's easier for for
someone like connor a high-level athlete
a high level performer to say
oh man if i if i only didn't drink or oh
man if i only didn't do this or do that
i could have gotten my comeback and
they're looking for an excuse yeah
they're giving themselves out there's a
lot of guys i played with man there's a
lot of dudes that i feel like they did
the these things because it's easier to
be seen as still having that potential
as potentially i still could have done
it if only i could have overcome these
demons as opposed to being like man i
just don't have it anymore or man i'm
just not good enough and i think that
that's that's part of this that's mental
health this is depression manifesting
yeah i don't i don't disagree here's the
other part that you have to be thinking
about when everybody was trashing tiger
i'd say do you even know what it is to
be the greatest golfer in the world and
you're black in a white sport and you're
crushing every do you know what it feels
like to be that guy do you know what it
is to be the guy that from two years old
he was a guy that was gonna be who he
was gonna become and then his dad said
and then he becomes that guy do you know
what it is to be person how many people
in the world have that kind of story
outside of lebron james maybe even
lebron james's father wasn't in a
picture so so the point is unless we
know
what it's like to be the guy that you
get on a fight
hundreds of millions of people want to
find out what the hell is going to
happen no one's going to understand it
so there's a part of it that conor is
gonna say who the hell are you guys to
even know what i'm going through right
sure it's always easier to give advice
from the outside so that's the other
thing that we need to also consider
because we have no idea what it is to be
the face of ufc for five seven years
bill barr with one of the greatest bits
of all time about that like oh yeah oh
you if you were in tigers position you
would have burned over yeah
yeah like like you've got a bus full of
swedish uh norwegian supermodels
mercury tracer to use your point right
there there's something to be said about
being married in that position versus
being single in that position yeah i
feel like for conor being married is
probably a blessing for him stability
family to be single to be this wild
crazy fighter who likes to drink that
can marriage only matters
by the way by the way i tell you what he
may be he may be doing tyson was married
too
but here's the difference he may be
doing stuff behind closers i don't know
i don't speculate because i'm that's not
my world i'm not in it and people can
say whatever they want to say they can
make it about anybody
but you got to give him credit his wife
is everywhere with him no matter where
he goes she's right next to him right so
there is a part of it where it's kind of
like look salute he puts the pictures
you know he put stuff from his family
it's not like he's hiding yet some guys
don't want to show that he's kind of
doing his part so who knows we'll see
what's gonna happen but is she being
that that stabilizing force or is this a
bonnie and clyde situation i don't know
we'll never know that i will tell you
this here's what i'm hoping i am hoping
he makes a comeback he has a big victory
and then he says here's what i'm doing
but i don't see that happening because
today's model of boxing he's going to go
probably fight jake because he's going
to make 30 million bucks on it he's
going to go find logan 50 million i want
him in the booth so bad i i i want conor
mcgregor sitting next to joe rogan
talking about conor mcgregor snoop in
the booth
yeah that would be that's the show okay
you guys only spent 30 minutes on connor
just so you know
we actually went deep on it so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]